hey Sal have you heard from your buddy
the psychic Long Island psychic didn't
she contact your dog for you or
something no my dog came to me my yeah
my dog visited me in a dream was it was
a beautiful thing my dog passed away on
his dog visited him in a dream where did
he have a dream now well it's a dream
Robin but it's called the visitation of
somebody passing so you had a dream and
you think he were visited by your actual
dog it's called a visitation let me ask
you something
don't you think a visitation would be
you're awake and then you see your dog
don't well
you I can have a dream about my dog
let's say it's a scenario I don't agree
around catching a frisbee that's not a
visitation okay my dog visited me in its
ruling form in my arms and in my dream
all right dream you're holding your dog
and it's glowing
yes it's glowing white and in my dream I
acknowledge is this a visitation I want
it because I want to validate this
I went in leaned into my dog and she
licked my face and it felt extremely
real and my dog was there and glowing so
was a day before because out of her the
death of a one year anniversary because
it was a dream but she was glowing it is
no longer a dream it is a visitation
it's technically it's a dream yes when
you're in a subconscious state yeah
that's the easiest way for spirits to
visit you so the dog visited me what you
don't think it was just a dream we'll
say you say it was not just the dream it
was a visitation it was a yeah because
the way the dream was structured a dream
could be any scenario how do you know so
much like how do you know the way it was
structured yeah how do you know the
visitation procedure or the structure
cuz I read up on this I do a lot where
do you read about this I read online of
course we found out about how to treat
your cholesterol that went horribly
wrong on our phone is Sal's dog falling
from heaven
hello yes bark once if you visited Sal
bark twice if you did not oh you did a
business I want you to bark once for yes
twice for no is Sal a dumbass oh ok
thank you that's not my dog how do you
know my dog would you know my dog said
goodbye to me Howard well my dog passed
away really in English no in Yugoslavian
Robin how did he do that
never Robin the dog was born in America
Robin so he said goodbye with his eyes
all right you ever hear of projection
what is projection you say you heard of
it
well projection is where you could
communicate without without auditory
response really yeah
that's not projection want to take
another guess